this is the entrance to the conrad pit
near salt gita the mine was shut down in
the 1970s an elevator takes the workers
down 1300 meters in ninety seconds
iron ore used to be mined here and
although the mining stopped years ago
there's still a lot going on
that's because it's being rebuilt as a
final disposal site for low and
intermediate level radioactive waste
theoretically radioactivity in the
storage facility will pose no threat to
human health or the environment
not even in the coming millennia
we keep coming up against new challenges
in the reconstruction
like rebuilding pits from the 1950s is
taking much longer than we'd hoped or
planned for
and all of that's a challenge that we
don't just have at conrad but at all the
permanent disposal sites it's taking
much longer and will be much more
expensive than we'd like
for years germany's energy companies
produced cheap nuclear energy and made
big profits
but in 2011 the government decided to
phase out nuclear power becoming the
first industrialized nation to do so
all nuclear power plants are being
gradually decommissioned
but dismantling the nuclear plants is
complex and costly and produces tens of
thousands of cubic meters of nuclear
waste
low to intermediate level radioactive
waste comes from contaminated tools
pipes and cables
those items can be cleaned and recycled
what remains is temporarily stored in
radiation leak-proof containers
as long as we're in a system where those
technologies generate profits there's an
interest to invest in safety and to
minimize the risks
but we face a big challenge
we'll soon have huge amounts of waste
huge amounts of nuclear waste that needs
processing
and we have to make it clear that's not
only an economic challenge but also a
social one
storing nuclear waste in old mines is
controversial
can the risks for humans and the
environment really be eliminated
at the conrad pit new facilities are
being built designed to provide the best
possible safety based on the latest
technology available
former miners are running the project
the conrad pit will be able to store
about three hundred thousand cubic
meters of radioactive waste in eight
hundred meter long chambers
building the repository is expected to
cost at least three billion euros
to cover the nuclear phase-out costs
energy companies have set aside funds
rwe has 10 billion euros in reserves eon
has about 14 billion but they worry that
the costs could get out of control
every year the reserves are examined and
verified by independent experts
but determining the size of those
reserves can only be based on the costs
we already know about
that is costs for dismantling plants
for processing waste and the planning
for the final repository
should the government and thus the
taxpayers share the costs if the money
runs out
the responsibility for the phase-out
clearly lies with the energy companies
for decades they received big subsidies
they have to provide the funding they're
legally responsible and that shouldn't
change
the first chambers for the nuclear waste
are ready
the waste will be stored in hermetically
sealed containers which will be covered
in concrete
the first containers are expected to be
moved to the conrad pit in five years at
the earliest